[Music]
what were the thing is is using the
outcome quality as a perfect signal for
deriving decision quality so let me give
you an example it's 2015 people will
remember the Super Bowl
the Seahawks against the Patriots and
the Seahawks are on the one-yard line
there's 26 seconds left it's second down
and they have one timeout and I think
that people remember that and they're
down by four by the way people remember
that famously Pete Carroll called a pass
play Russell Wilson passed the ball it
was intercepted and the next day the
headlines were let's just say pretty bad
for Pete Carroll so they were you know
worst play in Super Bowl history you
know Pete Carroll's I think some of them
called him an idiot but you know
headline after headline after headline
after headline was about how completely
ridiculous this call was now there were
a couple of out line voices one of the
main ones was a guy named Benjamin
Morris over at 5:38 and he went through
some of the analytics on the play and
actually had very very good arguments
for why that was at worst you know
reasonably thought through and possibly
quite a brilliant play if you were just
thinking statistically it's easy to see
what's happening here right because all
you'll have to do is the thought
experiment and the thought experiment is
this Pete Carroll calls the pass Russell
Wilson throws it and it's caught in the
end zone for a touchdown and just take a
minute and think about what those
headlines would have been the next day
instead of worse play in Super Bowl
history they would have been Carroll
outsmarts Belichick you know it would
have been about his creativity this is
the kind of thinking that got him to the
Super Bowl in the first place this is
why he's the best coach in the NFL and
deserves that ring now obviously whether
the ball is caught her dropped does not
actually change whether the decision was
a good one
but we act like it does and that's what
resulting is
[Music]